[Music]
[Music]
so questions let's talk about questions
why our question is important questions
are critically important because first
and foremost thinking what goes on here
is largely asking yourself questions and
answering them secondly if you want to
get anything in life chances are it's
inside someone else's head the knowledge
the skills the blueprint and the pickaxe
for getting that gold is in the form of
questions all right so there are few
things you can do to improve questions
number one is study questions watch
inside the Actors Studio listen to Terry
Gross listen to podcasts whether mine or
Joe Rogan's or others so that you can
borrow questions and test them on other
people and there are few things to
consider when you're formulating
questions number one is can it be
answered relatively quickly so for
instance if you found someone you
idolize you're in an elevator oh my god
it's Jimmy Fallon if you asked Jimmy a
question could he come up with a really
concrete answer in five seconds or less
the answer's no find a different
question for you or for other people so
what is your favorite book for instance
not a good question because people have
read hundreds or thousands of books in
many cases but what book or books have
you gifted the most to other people it's
gonna be a short list the search query
is really refined it's fast click
alright much like asking yourself what
makes me happy is not really a great
questions too broad and it takes too
long to search but let's just say what
makes me feel most relieved after work
when I get home or what activities which
people all right now we're more refined
you can answer it much more quickly and
it's more actionable think also of the
sequence of questions so if you want to
ask someone as I do very often a
question that could be kind of heavy or
really involved like what
you put on a billboard if you had a
gigantic billboard metaphorically
speaking to reach millions or billions
of people what would you put on it all
right that's that's a fair amount of
pressure and people in my case know they
might get quoted so to get them warmed
up and ready for that I don't lead with
that I'll ask them other questions that
are much much easier and less
intimidating
so what purchase of $100 or less has
most positively impacted your life in
the last say year a recent memory or the
books question and that gets them
flowing it gets them engaged and then I
can ask a question like that another
trick you can use when you ask what
might be a difficult question is you can
give an example so it could be a
personal example or it could be
something else so if I ask someone what
is something absurd that you love doing
because I want that little shred of
personality I don't want to just have
the actionable business stuff I want to
get to know them as a human and I will
then say well for instance the number
five five five is good luck to me for
many reasons so when it appears on my
phone I take a screenshot and die
elaborate a little bit or Cheryl Strayed
or Wilde likes to disassemble sandwiches
and rearrange all the ingredients so
each bite is uniform that gives them 30
seconds to think about their answer and
gives them some examples all right a few
things you should not do if you meet
someone who is say just above your
weight class in terms of professional
development and you want to connect with
them don't ask them questions that you
could answer on google number one all
right number two don't ask them really
broad questions they couldn't
conceivably answer quickly right what
should I do
what advice would you give me for
succeeding these are not good terms
if you can't define success in say 10
words or less get rid of it lose it from
the question all right and I would
encourage you to strive to be interested
in the form of good questions if you
seek to be perceived as interesting stop
talking
start thinking about questions and then
stop and listen hey guys if you're
enjoying the tips and tactics and how-to
on this channel or in the podcast the
Tim Ferriss show I made this for you
tribe of mentors short advice from the
best in the world this is the book that
I wanted to read so I went out and I put
it together created a dream list 130 of
the best at what they do people who are
icons legends and asked them all the
same questions these are people in some
cases I wanted to reach out to my whole
life ranges from many many billionaires
cofounders of every company imaginable
elite athletes ranging from surfing to
tennis to powerlifting everything else
country stars actors directors and you
can spot the pattern so some of my
friends have said this is the easiest to
read most useful book that I've put
together yet so check it out tribal
mentors dot-com you can find sample
chapters the whole list of mentors
everything tribal mentors calm